might be drunk we might be
drunk as long as we are
hanging out you know we might be drunk
raise a glass
let's talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a
bit
maybe drunk we might be drunk
yeah holy hell
here we are we're in the bar folks this
is it
the booze den the den of sin the
i hate man cave anything but man man
cave is annoying
yeah anything man in front like you're
going on a little man date
right now i'm getting dinner with a
friend exactly
i hate all the man stuff manatee
you name it uh but yeah so here we are
matt built us a bar it's insane
we're gonna put fan art on the wall
notice the paulie walnuts
soprano thing this is crazy it's crazy
we got rodney records we got meta
knights uh
this racket makes me think of uh when
they're playing tennis and annie hall
for some reason oh he just feels very
new
that's true i like it yeah this whole
thing's a racket
and uh we're figuring it out we got a
bartender over here
what's going on dan how's it going
you're six twelve you got a great head
of hair
you got an apron on what's shaking you
look like one of the inglorious bastards
oh yeah yeah you look bad i don't know
maybe like a mix of like eli roth
and uh any of the other ones like like
you got a badass vibe is my point i'll
take it i i got the
size shaved but i got it faded so i
don't look too much like a nazi you know
perfect we'll call you the beer jew
instead of the bear jesus
the beard i love it there we go
he looked huge in that eli roth is like
5 10. but they filmed him he looked so
manly at the chest hair
i don't know if this is true but i i
heard somewhere that it was supposed to
be a bigger role and it was supposed to
be sandler
but he dropped out to do funny people
because apatow is it but he's great and
funny people he is
but well that's a whole movie about him
but yeah i feel like sandler's not
tough i like him but but he but no but
90s sandler was just like [ __ ] [ __ ]
up i feel like that's true happy gilmore
he's the
good point get your spanish yeah that's
true he could go angry
i also heard that uh they were going to
make bob barker one of the nazis
and he used to [ __ ] out the sand but
they described the whole thing after
that
right right you're not pure white [ __ ]
oh yeah did you hear tarantino on on any
of the podcasts i
listen to everyone i'm a huge fan he
listens to everything he's the best
he had some great points i got to tell
you yeah we're talking
directors and screenwriter i watched
this documentary called milius
it's about john miley's he wrote
apocalypse now he wrote red dawn
you know the scene in jaws where they go
it's a doll's eyes
he wrote that whoa the industry hated
him
he hated hollywood but he was such a
genius screenwriter
that two things that i when i saw this i
was like i gotta tell sammy about this
they hated him in the uh in the room and
he would go he would go pitch a show and
he's like they hate me they hate me
pitch a movie and they're like no you're
a genius just pitch so he pitched this
movie
big detailed long story they go i don't
know we hate it and he goes well not
everybody likes macbeth
he pitched to macbeth and they turned it
down so he just proved to them
another story he wrote a script they go
it's too edgy it's too dark you got to
clean it up
so they had a guy cleaning up like a
little nerd guy and they said whatever
pages you change make those pages blue
they turn their script in with all blue
pages it was the same script and they go
we love it wow it just they just hated
him
they hated him damn but they thought
because the other guy wrote it and they
changed it this will be great now but
that's like
did you ever hear the val kilmer story
about how he tried to get uh
the doors oliver stone i don't know if
it's true it's one of those like old
hollywood tales right where
apparently the the rumor is that
he's like please give me this part i
know i can play jim morrison yeah
if you don't believe me i'm gonna send
three clips of
or two clips of jim morrison one of me
if you can tell them apart i'll stop
bothering you uh-huh
and he just sent three clips to jim
morris ah i've heard that that's [ __ ]
pretty cool good for val he's got cancer
is he all right he's got the thing dude
he's such a badass
i love dude i loved val kilmer love heat
love top secret we love you bang bang
yes he's great i was talking to uh
a friend once and what i've heard is
that he
like he'll just because he was in uh
[ __ ] he was in some movie shop gun no no
no no no no
he's great in top gun well anyway he
texts a guy a comedian i can't say his
name who he didn't know that well but
he's like hey can i sleep your place for
five
for five
[Laughter]
my place is under construction can i
just stay at your place and the guy's
like i barely know this guy this is
pretty weird and he just has like val
kilmer walking around his apartment in
underwear
wow val kilmer is just walking around my
place this is the weirdest thing ever
he's like he's a great guy he's yeah
it's just it's val kilmer it's weird
that's the cool thing about the old days
you could just walk around in a guy that
would be on tick tock now
and all this reels no this wasn't that
long ago oh okay
i think the guy he stayed with just
wasn't an [ __ ] right exactly exactly
sorry i'm all i'm all coughed up here
i'm sorry man
i can't believe first off you're engaged
oh
geez yeah i forgot i can't believe you
didn't mention that you were gonna pop
the question
yeah he's a hot guy no i just uh i don't
know i don't want to bother anybody
it's how's that you think confiding in a
friend
is a bother that's something you need to
bring up in therapy probably yeah
because i text list and i was like mark
is engaged and he goes
what ah i was like i would hope you told
one of us you were going to do it
yeah i don't know what i was thinking i
just i just was so focused on nailing it
and by the way i flubbed the hole and i
choked really
well it's so intimate i got intimacy
issues so i got down on one knee and i
was like
i love you and she's like yeah and uh
i said you know will you marry me and
all that you know it was great she cried
will you marry me yeah yeah so
i i speak for a living i'm on stage
every night and i i was on one knee and
i just
choked damn it's so heavy it's a heavy
moment
yeah it is a heavy moment yeah and it's
different you see the movies you see all
this [ __ ] but uh
you know in the in the moment it's
different and we had a great moment i
did it
and there was two old people on the
beach sunbathing two like fat
80 year olds and after i did it she's
hugging me we're crying and she go
the old people go oh that's nice there's
a nice little
that's all right rom-com moment there
you do any special that night
oh yeah we were in martha's vineyard we
we told the family
we it was all perfect nice yeah
did your family react like were they
excited you know
they gave me a high five and a shoulder
punch
it was good it was perfect they were
cool
they're just happy i'm doing something
uh you know adult
what a weird reaction to marriage yeah
there we go
all right right say it again i think
this calls for a drink event yes hello
mark can we introduce dan yeah yeah the
beer jew
dan is here he's a cocktail cockologist
what is it
mixologist yeah i'm a cocktail architect
you know liquor engineer all those
things oh [ __ ]
well we got our own rye on the way so uh
we're ready for fat cat for sure
way excited yeah all right he's what do
you got here
this is an amaretto and bourbon
sour oh wow today
oh boy that's the recipe i'm working on
so uh
you guys get to try it before it comes
out oh damn last week we had white cloth
so we're really stepping it up here you
know i'll make white clothes i don't
care man
yeah all right what's is this like
you're
like are you always trying to outdo
yourself like with recipes like are you
just working [ __ ] out all the time
oh constantly i mean like we're
constantly making recipes and like new
drinks and everything and right now i'm
working on like uh
actually right now i'm trying to run a
full recipe sheet of uh bodega
bartending
so like next to every liquor store
there's a bodega right yeah and what do
you do when you're pregaming you get
like a bottle of booze and some shitty
mixer and you go and take either like
really sad
quick shots you pet a cat yeah yeah you
pet a cat or
you know like you or you mix it together
but uh for me like i'm doing
uh recipes where you can make like
elevated drink like a nice whiskey sour
like this with
only things you find at your bodega and
at your average
ah i like it the poor man's liquor
exactly yeah yeah to the point where
like you don't even need a shaker you
got hot and sour soup last night use
that tin
poke shake it up poke holes in it that's
your strainer right holy hell
nice like a life hack like that exactly
heck for life all right uh
all right man very exciting all right
what is the real height six seven
six seven yeah are you six seven oh my
god i used to work at a carnival
oh man look at the swords in there holy
[ __ ] hey come on
drink it on antibiotics folks what other
pot is doing that
these are not bragging rights
it's like the chris rock joke i never
see my kids what do you want a cookie
[Laughter]
that's pretty good man i like drinks for
like see i like the taste of alcohol but
it's nice to have a drink that's that
smooth
hell yeah and the circular ball of ice
is a nice touch there
you like balls near your mouth don't you
there we go see i knew it
thank you no i like the balls of ice
they're really cool man hey man new new
studio
you got fancy new drinks there you go
you got that right gotta keep it classy
now right this feels moving on up
feels very out of place i mean we love
having you here we love the studio we
got
salacuses fat ass on the on the blower
here but
uh this this is not i'm not used to this
this does sallock does he kind of looks
like the uncle that falls asleep after
thanksgiving right now
isn't it that's true never kleiner yes
he does
a man who has his chair you know those
when like my grandpa
was like that they were like no one sit
in grandpa's chair yeah it's not like
that special chair like the him it is
that's treasure the dad with the chair
yeah my grandpa had the chair too that
is so weird that just
kind of happens my grandfather had an
ice maker in his
house and i remember the thing as a kid
like this is the height of luxury
he's got an ice shaker like a maker he
would scoop it
good times i love him man well this is
exciting so you're you're
going to be married i can't believe
you're going to be married i've known
you for sure
it is adult it's funny to say it's funny
to call
marriage adult yeah but it is there's no
kids getting married it is adult
totally and i will say it's a load off
you know you're just like all right
we did have a good night yeah exactly we
we got we got that going she's got a
ring yeah by the way the ring is a
is a nightmare to do you got to figure
that out get the sizing what she wants
i hit up her sister thank god wow that
was a whole
behind-the-scenes thing but you think
i'll give her a ring but you got to get
the right ring what if she hates the
ring it's
yeah that's a big one and then she's
like where's the wedding gonna be what's
with
food i'm like i thought i was done oh my
god yeah so
buckle up fatty damn you gotta you're
gonna have to give us a far out date so
we're not uh we're not working well
we're doing it in new orleans and we're
gonna do it like on
a weekday so try to get some comics but
i understand it's uh
it's a destination destination wedding
how do you decide new orleans i mean she
picked it
really she lives in boston boston's ugly
and boring you know
is a wild place for a wedding it's a
party town you go there for celebration
for booze
for weddings for funerals you know
i was i was just in nashville man i got
to tell you like i've never been to
nashville like
so fun broadway that's like bourbon
street
[ __ ] cancun that's crazy yeah it's a
honky-tonk bourbon
they are basically
as far as the eye can see i've never
seen more tiaras in my life
someone had to be removed from my show
because she wouldn't stop vomiting on
herself
wow some guy complained i didn't get to
see the last 10 minutes of your set
because as a woman wouldn't stop
vomiting and i was like wow that's a bad
act
i can't stand this guy's jokes
holy [ __ ] yeah that's a great club yeah
it's good it's a good time man yeah lucy
zanny's nashville
shout out great time where were you just
i was in houston that's right big room
yeah big crowds big people big state
just uh i think that's where i got sick
but you know you get after it every
night and the
people they're rowdy you know just
hooting and hollering something about
texas and florida you land there you're
like give me a
cowboy hat and uh a rail
like you just want to like party yeah i
had a guy
i was like i couldn't tell what kind of
hat he was like what is that and he goes
to stetson i was like i'm supposed to
know
what a stetson is i'm i mean yankee dude
right right
he was so pissed off then it turned out
he also had an ankle bracelet so i'm
like maybe you should be more worried
about you know
yeah yeah exactly i had an old joke it's
like
they hate the mask but they wear the
cowboy hat i know i'm like it's so silly
the cowboy i don't get it i know uh it's
a
what do you call it sacrilegious or hat
religious whatever but it's
it's silly you're not you're not riding
a horse
yeah didn't wasn't it uh joe list had
the bit about how you're in uh
you're you're you're in the cowboy store
like but i remember and you're just
mocking them they're like that's
like my whole life that's my thing yeah
and then he had the great tag where he's
like i wonder if they come to new york
put on glasses and go i'm a nerd i have
anxiety
that's a killer joke oh yeah he's pretty
good that that
string being there dude this is
incredible this studio we got the rick
and morty
thing the uh sorry it's a great sign
really this is not a great sign that
you're coughing on yourself
he's been covered tested folks yeah
completely reckless but
you're just coughing on yourself you're
drinking
booze yeah but hey the show must go on
we got i wanted to see the studio i
wanted to see you
i feel like this is hamlet yes exactly
we gotta push through this is my little
skull i love it dude this is a damn good
if you're going to drink
and a little bourbon's not horrible for
a cold right good point good point you
have one i think you have one you're
okay
i think you're right i'll have a hot
toddy when i'm sick every once in a
while
yeah cut to me on the amtrak just you
know yakking i'm like that girl at your
show here
but it's it's an hour and a half ride
i'm going to philly eight shows
we keep adding shows that's exciting
that's a great club helium
great probably my favorite are you there
two show sunday that means two tonight
to sunday to
friday to saturday that's incredible
yeah
i'm there and i think september i'm
looking for i love that club love that
club but
ah i wish i wasn't sick i want to like
dive in you know
yeah but just do take care of yourself
like that's the thing is you got to pace
yourself with this [ __ ] because
you know you're on the road every week
so am i you can't just like yeah you're
right
cut loose like oh man i saw nate
pargotsy in uh
nashville we talked for hours after the
show oh nice such a great guy to see
such a great comic
he's hilarious full of wisdom yes he
really is so
don't get into politics with him but
yeah he's a he's a
brilliant man that kid and boy he is
shot to the moon like he's
legit famous comedian and he did it with
his act he's like great he's a great
comment
that was act i was in la i was on the
road for over two weeks so wow
i mean i did some some hot la shows man
saw you know anthony jeselnik bill burr
burr is like
the best i was so embarrassed i don't
with the mass and everything you don't
recognize people sometimes so i
literally get off stage
and some guy in a mass sunglasses and a
hat goes hey sammy
and i'm just like oh hey yeah maybe hey
sam whatever hey sam
and i was just like oh what's up and
then and he goes oh okay
i was like and then i turned to
someone's like when does bill burke get
here because i don't want to see his
friends right
and they go he goes i'm here and i was
like oh jesus i'm sorry
man and no one hates big timing more
than birds it was
a mistake i just didn't know who it was
i thought it was someone i didn't know
but he didn't know that
it wasn't big time i mean i'm aware we
love the guy but i'm just saying
that's how he probably read it no i
don't think so but why would anyone
big-time him no he said i thought we
were better than that but it's all right
yeah you see christ yeah yeah well you
know comics we need an ovation when when
a comic walks in you gotta believe when
it's someone you haven't seen in a while
yeah and i i love seeing him he's the
best he's the man he's the best
probably one of the best uh cooking or
ever
[ __ ] i went cooking you whenever now i
gotta go ever i buried you on that [ __ ]
ah he's one of the best he's a legend
mount rushmore
i'm sick of mount rushmore by the way oh
why do i have to limit my forecast
now we're good in a four yeah and what's
that with four star five star which one
is it i don't like the whole favoriting
thing you know and here's the other
thing remember like myspace back in the
day this is my top
10 or whatever why are we always ranking
people how about we just our friends
bad news that's also lighting that's
like girl [ __ ] yeah it is girls
because you have bridesmaids you know
right guys there's a best man there's
just one
ah it's like it's not as competitive i
don't know
yeah good point good point yeah that's
true that is
it just leads to i don't even like the
best man idea i don't love best man
either because then
your other friend goes geez i thought i
was in there it's just all
bad because you're picking and choosing
yeah
i don't like i don't like ranking people
but people love ranking they love last
comic standing
top ten list survivor yeah the top three
po i mean the podium it's all podium
it's the olympics
yeah bronze what do you think of that
biles huh
uh you know i think here's about
here's my take on it if you work that
hard to get there
and you think you gotta go you gotta go
interesting like cece sabathia one of my
favorite baseball players ever yankee
alcoholic his whole career he bailed on
the yankees one year to go to rehab but
it's like four's family dude like i
think if you if you were like this is
life and death
yeah for me like all right what if she
wins and then kills herself
jesus like i think mental health is real
i i believe in that stuff so
uh you know i i did tweet uh i'm gonna
take
a step away from my mental health to
continue to pursue stand up
but uh great but i
yeah i'm i'm with it i just heard
sabathia on on fresher yeah i mean he
was an alcoholic he was oh [ __ ]
and he was a pitcher so when you're a
pitcher you can kind of get away with
being an alcoholic because you you
throw like once every five days right
right so he'd be like i'd pitch
i'd party after that night i'd be
hungover [ __ ] i'd drink the next day and
then i kind of recover for three days
yeah but
but like when you but he would go i mean
he's 300 pounds
right he would drink a shitload uh
yeah it's like andre the giant they said
he had like eight cases four bottles of
wine and
you know imagine getting [ __ ] up with
andre the giant oh my god that'd be a
nightmare
you couldn't keep up and then they said
he would fart he had a huge dick
takes three people to carry him into the
water [ __ ] unless you have hulk hogan
he carries him to the
hotel imagine that uber like no no no no
no don't come in no english yeah right
yeah he must be a nightmare to get
around that guy but uh
what was i gonna say oh uh oh biles my
thing is
i get it look do what you gotta do
protect the health but like
i don't know don't sign up and uh take
someone else could have had that spot
true so that sucks but i guess you could
you already got a silver though right
i don't know i mean she's is she not the
best ever i think she's definitely the
best ever
i don't know yeah i i also think like
man i don't give a the olympics just
kind of i don't give a [ __ ] either
people are all
right give a [ __ ] it's like it's it's
patriotism i get like
i care about like team usa basketball
and we're getting embarrassed man oh
yeah that's
crazy it's like differences in
philosophies because
popovich who's like this genius coach
but then all the players are young and
he's an old guy and
i think there's there's a clashing on
what you know what they what offenses
they think they should run
oh what yeah so it's a bummer to see
america i mean i just you think of
america's the dream team but these other
countries have gotten pretty good now
our players are better but they just
have better chemistry
interesting man i thought we were the
king of of b-ball
we invented it we don't have our best
player like lebron
isn't playing james horn's not playing
kyrie a.d like all these great players
trusts aren't playing
why wouldn't you want to i mean an
olympic medal i would just be like all
right we've already got one
oh he's got one and i get it like the
[ __ ] guy's old he doesn't want to
keep playing
like in the off season too it's year
round you got to protect he's
been injured all year it just doesn't
feel like the olympics are what they
used to be
it used to be like this insane event
like if you win
you're a huge yeah now i think you get
more clout for pulling out
yeah you get you get some sponsors
she'll probably get a therapy
app or something and uh she's already
got the gold
therapy app this is a great business
move now she's gonna get some uh
some love from you know meditation with
biles hey
flip right this way or whatever flip
your life around
yeah that's a good idea you got jumping
hurdles me too
come on by we'll get you feeling better
or whatever it is you know
pretty genius yeah and kevin space you
can do the me too app
for everybody yeah and pull out i get
the pulling out
i love pulling out but why do we have to
throw her a party
just pull out hey you're out i'm
throwing her a party i i those are the
other people
like people like you're my hero that's
what's weird okay well that to me is
also
crazy you know this is yeah she's be
your hero for
you know being a great athlete but like
look it's good to say
focus on your mental health i think
that's good i do think we use the word
hero a little too much
oh for sure yeah yeah like michael
phelps like when people even call him
like a hero it's kind of like
if you're a kid it's good that but if
you're an adult and you're like that's
my hero that's [ __ ] weird
that's super weird and it just feels
like we pick something and we just
everybody has to go that way and if you
don't if you go the other way you're
you're a piece of [ __ ] or whatever so i
don't think the olympics are good for
your mental health i mean no
i don't think any of these people are
like i am connected to a bunch of other
people
right you are literally training all day
think about the you know she's been
sexually assaulted like think of the
abuse
in the gymnastics world right sure if
you're a gymnastics coach
you should have a background check like
you're assumed you're in [ __ ] isis or
something i agree that should be the
background
oh you want to train teen girls with
tight bodies
we're going to need a minute to go over
everything you've ever done
also true we got the taskrabbit
backstory we should have this guy's
exactly there's been about you oh uber
got interviewed yes
uh and they probably haven't by the way
but uh
you know yeah so that's another thing i
also think about like michael phelps
everyone talks about like he [ __ ]
hated swimming like
that really well that'll make you hate
it right like think about the hours you
have to train
to be that great ah you
learn i think you just start to hate it
and you lose your life and basketball
you can like kind of
you have other people around training
you you have a connection swimming you
were just in the pool
doing laughs i think the mental
toughness like remember when diana nyad
swam from cuba to uh florida it was like
61 miles of swimming
she's getting stung by jellyfish the
whole time she's 61 years old
can't you get a pool i mean i think she
was like one of the things
i want to do this and you're like you
know cubans have done this
yeah yeah cubans have done this that's
how they got here
right but yeah but she was like i'm
gonna do this with like people
monitoring me i think that's pretty
amazing to me that's one of the most
amazing athletic feats
just mentally to totally going totally
yeah and but
maybe you have to have that to be an
olympic winner
oh yeah you have to it's mental
toughness too i mean you
i just think when you're swimming for 61
miles you didn't check your phone
for that that alone is impressive that's
a good point yeah
yeah no waterproof phone down there
that's a great point yeah
yeah i i'm with you it's it's crazy i
just don't think people care as much
like do you what do you give this a [ __ ]
sally what do you get
financially if you win a gold because
i'm sure this country
here i'm sure there's some uh it's about
the endorsements it's not about the
winning the goal
i think you get a little cash prize
though oh no
no no you get money if you want an oscar
too by the way nobody talks about that
how much i think it's like 100 grand or
so really yeah which you know
nothing to sneeze at yeah but it's
really about like
you will continue to work you would hope
yeah of course thank god who's the guy
in uh in the heat of the night who's
that actor
not sydney partier though the white guy
rod steiger
oh the white guy yeah he could not get a
job after he won the oscar for that
movie
is that right yeah what is that and
sydney partier couldn't after either
neither of them could what
he didn't win though paudier says here
um
olympics and paralympic athletes are
awarded
37 500 to gold winners and 22
500 to silver winners weird that's
something that's something
but then they get two of michael phelps
comes back eight of those
all right right and then the sponsor
who's paying these guys
i mean like the olympic committee okay
this is so low
um but sorry what were you saying no i'm
just i mean
michael phelps like subway like every ad
he oh yeah this dude is
worth bruce jenner that's why he's she
uh caitlyn jenner i'm talking about
bruce right now so settle down people
bruce when bruce is the olympic champion
wheaties boxes that's where you get
that net worth is all the sponsorships
right right right yeah he was you i mean
remember phelps got in trouble for
smoking weed
yeah that was big he hit a bong load or
something and he lost a cheerios ad or
some corn flakes
all i that's all all i saw which first
off
i should be embracing of course who eats
more [ __ ] corn flakes than
potheads also this dude's eating
probably so much of your [ __ ] when he's
high exactly and then also
yeah michael phelps good boy michael
velasquez
is he's probably like i
am so burnt out mentally because you
have to focus so much
he said let me let me turn it off for a
second of course what do you do after
you [ __ ]
take like a big exam in school you get
[ __ ] up
what do you do when you have like a big
work presentation you get drunk or you
you take an edible or something you want
to shut down
see american these are human beings who
should be allowed to shut down
and we it's also funny how weed has just
the perception has changed so much
i know and they got [ __ ] back in the
day but it's all changed they should get
they should get reimbursed oh man you
watching move from the 40s they're like
we locked him up real good he was
smoking a reefer yeah
yeah i got a jazz cigarette that [ __ ]
criminal
like no now it's like a healthy thing
now doctor's like hey you got glaucoma
have some uh maui wowie or whatever the
[ __ ] you know i mean have you been to
one of those distilleries
no oh the weed places were they called
dispensaries dispensary
yeah it's insane it's crazy they have
like crackers out
i know it's wild and i'm not a good weed
guy
so people like try this try that i'm
like if i eat this i'll be cuddling the
cat
in this corner right now you're pushing
feelings away and weed makes you in your
head
and i'm the same way i mean yeah like
probably bonded over alcohol is because
you shut down
here here well you got to shut down
every now give me give me the oscar
money
please also i feel bad you're sitting
there
i want to put you to work a little bit
all right man oh i'm good i'm good
helps to loosen the mucus can i get
another one of these or is that
is that horrific that's up to you bud
all right
can we go maybe a little less sweet no
problem
i'm sweet enough as they say
all right thank you dan absolutely your
boys are not your doctor so i got you
man
well they were considered doctors back
in the day yeah it's like you know
you got ghosts in your blood do some
cocaine about it right they called it
elixir
or you know some [ __ ] they uh
yeah that's dude i uh i gotta give you a
wreck i got a couple
oh please yeah a couple good wrecks
first off this is a salaccus wreck to me
that i finally watched so i gotta shout
out salacuse for giving me this wreck
the taking of pelham one two three from
the 70s
the one with walter matthau and uh
robert shaw
mm-hmm dude it's incredible jerry
stiller's in it
wow oh thank you oh yeah i'll take one
more too
just the new york scenes alone i mean so
badass so gritty 70s baby one of the
best new york movies of all time
probably yeah i can't believe i've never
seen it it's one of those movies where
so basically a subway car
gets taken hostage yeah and
walter matthau is you know kind of the
mta guy who's in charge
he's like he's like a transit police
which i didn't even know existed i'm
going to be honest
like of course they exist but i didn't
put it together yeah and
uh jerry stiller what i love about these
guys is literally
every person who is informed about the
hostage situation on the train
is annoyed it's the most in new york ah
perfect literally every character is
like
there's been a train overtaken they're
like ah this is exactly what i need
today that's my route
yeah that's perfect that's how it should
be it's the best so
good so good when you watch it with this
guy he gets all misty because it brings
him back to his youth
because he's 68 years old but he has
great movie rex this guy
oh yeah he gets it he knows what's up uh
[ __ ] i gotta give you a wreck oh my
wreck's not as good as that
i got another one too please you go you
go first well i was going to say
uh i hope uh nobody's done this but
or help i haven't done this already but
i think i might have done this
oh it's streaming on amazon by the way
if you want to watch it oh there you go
amazon
uh keep airborne in the house
you got airborne i i don't believe in it
really
there was an article a while back just
calling it a croc i mean if it's zinc
then i
i get i i think it's a placebo oh no
well i am i feel bad i'm the sick guy
pushing airborne so maybe it is
worthless
oh we uh yeah i mean i think is that a
croc
sally i don't know look it up i think
it's [ __ ] yeah i just spent
80 bucks because i used to swear by it
but i i just do zinc i do like coldies
are good for me
maybe i'll do zinc coldies are my my
go-to when i'm
i take them even when i'm not sick if i
just feel like allergies or anything
coming on i pop a coldies but then do
you worry that
you know your body will need it
no all right airborne agrees to pay
23.3 million dollars to set a lawsuit
because they made false claims about
i got stacks of it in my apartment i
remember seeing an article and they were
like this is
because i used to take it all the time
and be like this is working but like
you just want to believe it's a cure i
know
i do at least oh what a shame these
are phenomenal look starter cherry some
of the best
oh yeah wait oscars didn't say
ah interesting say that uh men's next
movie they get a raise of 4.3 million
and women get a raise of
500 000. shut up [ __ ] horrible
well you know this story laputa lupita
nyong'o from uh
12 years a slave way to kill that name
that was a risk
i got it you got it that was she's great
she's a great actress but she
got 13 000 for 12 years a slave oh my
gosh
yeah i don't know and i think she won
the oscar or she got nominated
wow she's a great actress she's
beautiful she uh there's a name for
those wages by the way
for those wages yeah
slave wages oh do you not see where he's
going that's a great joke i was thinking
about
an angle that's great well done
well it's really you know coffee is a
slave is a brutal movie
i couldn't watch i used to have a bit
about how i saw it in one of those
theaters with reclining chairs you're
like this isn't the way to
you don't want to see this in a
luxurious setting but uh
i remember i went to the cellar after i
saw that movie because i was like [ __ ]
you know like oh my god what up brutal
film
and uh i walk in and i tell i said keith
robinson and i was like
have you seen it i was like oh it's a
terrific film and he's like shut the
[ __ ] up
you're not allowed to say that there's a
white comic i'm sorry what
it's good movie i know but he's like you
said it too too joyously
all right fair enough i loved it
wonderful
yeah it was great that's funny keith is
so funny check out keith robinson
the best funniest guy hey folks
we might be drunk is brought to you by
good old honey
yes you know you do the online shopping
we're all hunting for coupon codes and
uh saving money codes and whatever the
hell you got to type into that
search box we've all been there but
we don't know the code how you gonna get
a deal without the code
you gotta be in some vip club or private
room
not anymore we all shop online and we've
all seen that empty promo code
just taunting us well thanks to honey
you don't have to search for one anymore
honey is free
and the browser extension that scours
the internet for discount codes when
you're ready to check out honey
automatically
applies the best one instant savings
honey has found its customers over 2
billion bucks in savings supported by
over
30 000 stores online buy anything you
want from tech
gaming beer wine you know we love that
it's a great idea you can just get a
free code to save you some dough why
wouldn't you do it
get on it screw clipping coupons
i i just bought some shoes i used honey
found a nice uh
promo cut me uh cut me down quite a bit
so you should do it too if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
up missing out on free savings it's
literally free
installs in just a few seconds save some
dough and support this pod get honey for
free
at joinhoney.com drunk
that's joinhoney.com drunk and get that
honey baby
[Music]
all right let me give you let me give
you uh another wreck oh i got a p
for you here hit me with a pu all right
okay this has always bugged me and i've
always known it bugged me but i could
never think of it and then it happened
to me and i wrote that [ __ ] down
instantly when someone offers you
something
like hey you wanna you know you want a
piece of bread or you want some cookies
i made and you say no
and they get pissed you know what i mean
you're at somebody's house they go
i made muffins you want a muffin you're
like oh i'm good and they're like geez
you don't want the muffin i'm like
so i gotta eat the muffin now because
you want me to eat the muffin
why are you hurt you offered it i think
those people are like
they feel good that you ate something
that feels good for you but what feels
good for you is actually not eating the
muffin right now
so they should they should hear you yes
that was like a therapist answer that
was really good
wow wow man i should should charge me
um yeah she drives me nuts people do do
that and like
it's tough especially people bring food
to shows sometimes i'm sure you get this
sometimes oh yeah it's like one's gonna
take food from a stranger i'm like i
don't know what kind of practical joking
the lunatic is like bringing brownies
that they laced with something
i know i eat every one of them really i
can't not eat it somebody brings me a
bounty
cookies i'm gonna eat them all yeah i'll
take it but yeah i just hate when people
offer because now you feel like all
right i guess i have to take it because
i don't want to hurt this person's
feelings
even though i don't want a turkey leg at
the moment you know
turkey leg's a tough one it's a bit
muffin's a little
you know and the booze is the biggest
one hey you want to drink nah
man i'm all right i got hung oh i'm
hungover i've never seen you turn down a
drink
that was a bad example but i just i hate
when they get upset when you
like you offer it i don't want it and
now you're mad at me i think some of
those people don't want to drink alone
too
that's the other thing like if they're
drinking they're like yeah have a drink
with me and you're like yeah you know i
get to wake up early and
yeah come on have one drink give me one
drink at a certain point you're like
at a certain point this is uh you know
it's a bit much
it's a lot but that's that's a if you
offer don't offer it
if it's if it's an empty gesture you
know you just want me to
have it yeah i don't know if your
feelings are on the line don't offer it
yeah you can't get it you can't get too
emotionally attached to the offer
yes that's what it really is exactly
because
i love a muffin but i mean i love a
muffin i'm the muffin man
but uh i got a muffin top but i'm just
saying
if i don't want the muffin it's not a
personal attack this is another one i
get a lot
i got a new phone and i go new phone who
is this whoa
oh you deleted me huh i'm like it's a
new phone yeah also
maybe i didn't save your number or that
i'll do a thing now where sometimes it
pops up on your phone the name
so you just don't save it maybe says the
name
so you forget to say it but then like
then they text you in like two months
right there's none of that right and
they're like oh you don't know and it's
just like look man
it's not personal it's not personal i'm
a [ __ ] mess yes except i'm the mess
yeah not you you're the egomaniac loser
i'm a mess right right fitzdog used to
have a great bit about like
you don't remember me like when he meets
a guy he's like ah and he's like what a
dick i'm like how about be more
memorable
you know like i don't this is my fault
you're boring
i'm ruining the bit but it was no but
it's a fair point yeah
yeah you know make a splash will you all
right well give me a peeve
let me give you one more rack first oh
okay so i just read this book called
uh uh
the big goodbye it's incredible it's
about old hollywood
if you like movies you will love this
[ __ ] it's oh
great uh it's
like chinatown uh roman polanski it's
about with roman polanski and the sharon
tate murder which is like brutal
but then it's about it's a lot about
jack nicholson who's just the [ __ ]
man he's the man as if i didn't love
jack nicholson already enough like it
just made me love him ten times more
because he turns out he's like the most
loyal dude
on the planet robert town was like oh
yeah crazy
i mean you know it's cool to see that
it's cool that there's still
yeah he punched up god oh okay he wrote
chinatown he punched up godfather he
like
uh he was like the script doctor punch
up bonnie and clyde he like say they
were like he saved every big hollywood
script and he was a genius but he burned
himself out on coke he would take coke
like
the way we'd take like an adderall whoa
but then he would also get he would
drink like vodka
but uh yeah he was uh ben affleck
whoa wow that could be dude i gotta say
affleck's a great director
is he i mean the town is incredible oh
he did the town
he started and directed the team wow and
uh the one with morgan freeman and casey
affleck
oh uh manchester by the sea no no no uh
it's a noir
oh look it up is casey affleck morgan
freeman ed harris
john ashton oh man i'm good with actors
nate yeah
titles uh how about oh dude some of the
stories in this
like oh it's a lot about robert evans oh
i love robert robert evans is
like the ultimate hilarious over-the-top
cliche hollywood character it's he's the
producer with the
feet on the desk and the cigar and he
steven talks that way you know he's like
dude
i told that hebrew to get off my lawn
you know
like he's so old-school he's that's how
he he called nicholson irish
he called yes yeah that mick he called
uh town the scribe
and he called and he called roman
polanski the polock i mean he just
called everyone he goes i got the three
best in town you tell me i'm not gonna
get it and of course he was like
terrified he's like chinatown's [ __ ]
the score was [ __ ] up but he would
[ __ ] the best one of the best scenes
is like this could be hilarious in the
scene
is he would always fight with like the
agents to get the rates lower for the
actors yeah so he's arguing with faye
dunaway's
because nicholson's just calling faye
dunaway he's on some set in europe every
night like
faye we need you we need you for this
we need you for this part we need you
for chinatown you are this character
yeah you'll nail it like any so like
faye dunaway was the biggest diva but
nicholson just knew who was gray so
so she loved him but she hated everyone
else of course
and everyone said hated her and he's
calling her every night faye
we need you and and then robert evans is
talking to her agent and
he's like i can 50 grand is the most i
give her and she's like she'll fire me
for that much for that offer
and she'll be right that's too low on
offer for faye dunaway and and he's like
jane fonda wants to part this is how we
get faye dunaway smart
and then and he's just like oh god damn
i'll see what i can do you piece of [ __ ]
and they're yelling at each other always
in negotiations but they were still kind
of friends
the next day she calls back you i won't
believe this but faye agreed to it he
goes i'll see what i can do
jane fonda really wants it still he
calls back and he's like all right you
you
dunaway's in yeah and she's like all
right agree handshake whatever
and then he pauses he's like i'll level
with you fun to pass
and then and she pauses and she goes
i'll level with you too
there was no ilya kazan project which
she was kind of building up
why she couldn't do it so it's like oh i
love it it's like one of the things
you're like oh man it's funny that
they they're both full of [ __ ] yes but
they both admit they're full of [ __ ]
it's a chess game it's
who's the better schmoozer who's the
better liar i love that [ __ ] there's so
many great scenes there scenes like
nicholson won't come to set
on chinatown because there's a lakers
game going into double overtime
and he's like i'm not coming out of the
trailers like jack come on he's like
he's like [ __ ] you like polanski takes
forever i just want to watch this one
part of the game
wow and then they lose he'll be in a
furious mood it's like
scenes of like nicholson's how tight he
was with
john houston yeah you know he's also
banging his daughter
on the set of chinatown and john
houston's just like sophisticated older
guy who's like
i see you're sleeping with my daughter
you know and then on top of it
he is banging the daughter in chinatown
away wow life imitates
it's crazy bart what about uh you've
never seen chinatown
oh love it uh big fan but
fun two things about nicholson one huge
dong yeah
yeah i saw a porn star on howard stern
when i was like 13 and she was like a
[ __ ] jack nicholson he's huge in the
pants and howard was like get out of
here you know because he's got a tiny
thing
won't do interviews oh is that right i
mean when do you ever see him get
interviewed
good point i mean he's got mystique well
he also thinks like if you see an artist
get interviewed how are you supposed to
believe them as all these characters
i love it i love it he's a guy i'm like
i'm worried they would try to cancel him
or something but he's so
uh he's so beloved sounds like he's not
that bad a dude although
the polanski thing did happen in his ski
house
i hope that comes up on the the picture
there peters
is that his dick he's a fake black dick
obviously
so oh and then the other thing i watched
some documentary on a photographer i
forgot his name sally but
they he's like he filmed or he photoed
all these huge celebrities in the 70s
and he's like i did the nicholson one he
showed up in a porsche
we shot it on the side of the road he
was super fun and jovial
and then he zooms into the photo and his
nose is all white
oh yeah just so much blow they were all
that was hollywood in like the early 70s
think about all the great movies though
from the early 70s and late 60s
hollywood
that was the golden age and then best
years another great last thing i won't
keep blabbing on about this one thing
that like to me was like amazing
is uh i mean the most horrible thing
ever the manson murders
polanski uh sharon tate pregnant
murdered all those people get murdered
in the house
and he was obviously scarred and then
they basically the origin the original
ending for chinatown spoiler
obviously we haven't seen it like zone
out for 15 seconds
you know down away murdered
and that wasn't the original ending
polanski made that be the ending because
and they basically said there was no way
he wasn't going to come back from europe
and go to la and not have a beautiful
blonde be murdered in the end
because that was how he saw l.a whoa
isn't that [ __ ] heavy oh
heavy damn that's heavier than the uh
hot tub rape well that was that chapter
was rough
oh really well yeah yeah i mean he
basically had a 15 year old
it ain't good geez he left and he never
came and nick nicholson wasn't there he
was gone it seemed like he was
but he also wouldn't turn his back he
wouldn't turn his back on any friends
nicholson
damn he just won't do it did he do any
polanski movies after that
i don't think so although they almost
did they almost did i think i think it
fell apart because nicholson wanted too
much money i think
yeah he's uh he's expensive dude i mean
the deal he got for batman is like the
greatest
greatest deal ever because he didn't get
it back end or something
he got like four percent of every batman
movie i think yeah
my god the only way he would agree it
was something insane every future
yeah something like that yeah it was
something insane he's made like
60 to 80 million off yeah
such as i love that movie i mean 1989 it
was like i was you know
seven years old or whatever but it was
just so silly he's got this purple suit
the big gun he's
dancing the prince you know he's so
great you know rub up another man's
rhubarb
like i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about but he just made it so
nicholson
and keaton was great too and keaton's
the man hot kim basinger too
oh boy those were good years yeah
i feel bad we talk about movies all day
long my my girlfriend was like uh or
fiance what a weird thing to say i hate
that word but uh
she was like god boys love movies men
love movies i'm like yeah i thought
everybody loved movies
what i would say this so think about all
the great movies
from like the 60s 70s a lot of them are
male leads most of them are
so i do think guys like just the last
like 20 years i feel like women have
gotten more complex roles in movies
maybe that'll get more into movies maybe
more women into it and they do say men
are more
visual ah so maybe it appeals to us in a
different way and
she'll watch this 90 day fiance [ __ ] i'm
like i don't know how you do this is
like
that's that drives me crazy i just i
just show my girlfriend uh
one flew over the cuckoo's nest we
watched that and she was like that was a
great one
oh really all right all right but she
felt for nurse ratchet in a way i did
not
interesting i [ __ ] hated nurse
ratchet we all said i was a kid how do
you feel for a nurse rather
she's dealing with she's dealing with
crazy people all day and she's like
nicholson's not even crazy like he's
there because he's
kind of an [ __ ] yeah interesting and
i was like that's an interesting take
although she also was needlessly mean in
my opinion i agree
she was a [ __ ] i mean when i was
watching that as a kid i related as the
as she was the teacher being so mean
that's so [ __ ]
i said the same thing to her that that's
why i was bad
all right that was exciting nicholson
nicholson was like the bad kid in class
yes but he was killing and he was killed
and he was likable and you had he was
charming you had to love him
dude the scene i got teary-eyed in the
scene you know the scene where he gets
the votes to watch the baseball game
yeah
the world series she goes great sorry
the baseball game even though he gets
the votes to watch the world
and she won't let him and then he just
starts narrating the game as if it's on
and everyone gathers around like [ __ ]
that
got me that was a special scene
beautiful brilliant
milo's foreman genius yeah yeah he also
did man on the moon
damn never saw that yeah it's okay i
mean jim carrey's amazing in it but
as a movie yeah i shouldn't say that's
pretty good i gotta give you a pee
give me a peeve i feel like we've gone
in the [ __ ] full cisco here i'm sorry
dude
we both love movies oh i know i'm gonna
peeve
i got a couple oh boy two this is a
small one i'll do a one on myself i like
peeving my
my own things that i do that annoy me oh
i love when you do a you fall on your
own sword first off this is one
on the road you ever do it in a hotel
are any of these uh
or any of these do not disturb signs did
the end of them not fall off the second
you open the door
ah yeah can we get one that sticks to
the [ __ ] door
that's true this feels like a maniscalco
bit these things
that fall off the door every time i'm in
a hotel
what's going on with these stickers yeah
you're right though
you open the door and they fly in like a
feather
every time but now they're they're get
they're gotten rid of them they don't do
the cleaning with the coven
they're still there though oh okay i
also i'm just terrified that i'm gonna
fly all day
do a show at night and get woken up at
eight oh been there
and they don't take no for an answer
you're like i'm good i'm good i think
that's how they get paid is that right i
think it's by room isn't it what
no give that a go i mean doesn't that
make sense
i always assumed it was like a like a
flight attendant then why do they want
to clean it so badly
i think they're just they can't hear you
i don't know earlier
ah that's interesting i think it's by
room they get paid by room
that's not fair because what if you just
have a shift where everybody's sleeping
in
i don't know is it like a waitress where
you want the good shift
i don't know i thought it was like a
flight attendant you know if you're
sleeping i don't have to serve you
you know so you get a break what do you
think there sally
okay let me give you another piece all
right looking this up this one's on me i
did this so i was in nashville
sorry flat rate per room there we go
what per room
per room i told you wow well i'll let
them in now i just feel bad there's so
much
semen on those on
[Laughter]
do i jerk off do i come on a towel yeah
the hotel what am i a monster
they have to clean those things well
where do you shoot it you think i want
them to pick it up and for it to break
like a cracker no i
uh oh [ __ ] i thought everybody did that
i go green this is gonna sound crazy
i jerk off into my palm and i and i dump
in the sink
all right i gotta get out of here
is that weird i've never heard anyone
say that my entire life here's my
defense
because sometimes i used to do it back
in the pillow some of those tissues are
bad
uh not pillow tissues pillow that'd be
crazy yeah yeah uh no
i doing the t-shirts a lot of jizz fills
up a pillow case
wait so you the tissues is not great
because it it's all over the place you
can't really aim it
i feel well my issue with the tissues
too is sometimes you put on your penis
and
some somebody gets stuck to the hole
yeah so i just started doing the hand
i'm not i can't come on the towels
that's a
that's a cruel move i thought i was
doing the right thing
i think you're doing the wrong thing wow
yeah when i leave those towels look like
i have no opinion i will tell you this
is the shitty thing i have done i don't
do it as much but i used to only trim my
pubes on the road
uh i don't like the cleanup at home that
makes sense
i tip extra that makes sense i think if
you do it over the toilet or in the
shower
i do i i i i tip extra in the room but i
always yeah i'll do uh
you don't want to just hit that on the
bed spread oh i won't trim my pubes over
the bed i do with the toilet
you can lay down get the legs up i don't
know why you're coming in your own hand
i don't know what else is going on
well then i wash my hands i've been
shaking your hands over 20 years
this is weird well i wash them i'm just
worried you're going to mix the pureel
in the jizz one day like all right i got
my sanitizer
muscle memory holy how don't you go with
purell
no no that would be burns too much of
loneliness right
well at least your dick's clean man
jerk off in the hand i don't know my
jizz is is very uh
temperamental it's sporadic is it yeah
it shoots at one of them that one drips
yeah exactly so
i like it you're trying to pull a green
thing you know i go green what are you
kidding
i just don't know the options are tissue
towel floor floors ridiculous drapes
the floor i like to open the bible and
jizz
and close it that's what i do
right on luke
this one that one's gonna get us uh
demonetized on youtube i think
yeah the bible's still in there i check
every time sometimes if it's one of
those uh
shampoo conditioner lotion shower i dump
a little in the conditioner
[Laughter]
just to mix it up just you know they
won't know the difference yeah that
guy's got a decent piece
on the left what about oh you found
ah you don't want that on your search
history bible jizz
man you're gonna get uh flagged
god hates flags it's not like there
aren't any in the church let's be honest
there's a kneeler for a reason folks how
weird is that for you
as a jewish guy with the confession box
and the pedophilia
is that kooky why is that kooky for me
well i said i went to catholic school
so i've kind of like seen it all front
and center
you know uh yeah i don't i mean jews
don't do confession we just kvetch
ah we just complain all the time we turn
complaining into an art form like
people it's funny jews will complain
this is not just jews
a lot of new yorkers do this too a lot
of new yorkers have taken on the persona
of jews like seinfeld is very new yorkie
right humor even if he's costanza just
be real he's a jew
yeah you know uh but you know you
complain and
it's amazing you just see a friend you
haven't seen forever and you're just
like
and then this happened and then i go to
the store and there's a line
yeah and then i go to the atm and
there's a line and then i get cut off in
traffic and then you're like all right
good talk that's all it is
like you're not you don't feel drained
because that's just like how they're
interesting it feels less like
draining yeah you're venting yeah
venting
sounds better than complaining yeah yeah
that's good
yeah that's good speaking of convecting
we got a jackie mason died
so that's a big big jewish comedian if
you haven't heard him on uh
fresh air with terry gross npr interview
very very good
i've never heard that worth listening to
his his real name is like yakov
amada or some crazy jewish name he was a
rabbi
yeah back in the day did you ever hear
him as the aardvark
no in those cartoons from like the 70s i
know he was in the simpsons
yeah okay well oh that's a great episode
great app
great app google that if you haven't
seen it
i love it give me his real name it's
coming some crazy i think he's russian
or hungarian
hideous hideous man but uh i mean he was
the jewish comic like that was his thing
there it
that's the is jewish name i've ever
heard it's crazy russian jew total
russian jew right there you go
i used to see him this is not even that
long ago within the last five years
jogging up with a backpack
in like full-on clothes bike captioning
not
backpack good available him 88 still
jogging how about that
good for him i'll tell you how old was
he when he er
93 isn't that right that's what it says
that's pretty good
he did pretty well i never have heard
one album yeah i don't really know his
stuff
wow he's from sheboygan nobody saw that
coming i just figured manhattan
or brooklyn sheboygan great word
it's a funny it's a good comedy word
breakup yeah
yeah or albuquerque what uh
oof sorry right i'm good eight shirts
this weekend we're gonna push through
folks yeah i'm a little worried
i'll be fine then we got a taping next
week all great timing
it's exciting man what uh so do you want
to plug the tape in
sure i mean uh it's i think you got to
go to theblacklist.com or one of those
for
tickets but there are tickets i'd love
to have some drunk fans there
just come out and support we need that
laugh
uh on netflix i could bomb i'm going
pretty dark
because i really want this thing to
stand out a little bit so it's abortion
it's trans it's anal it's squeeze it's
black it's white
it's day it's night thank you
so yeah we're going all the way down man
i'm excited to see this edison ballroom
in midtown old supper club nice
yeah it looks pretty set i googled the
room and it's
pretty beautiful old-school ornate
and it's tighter you know the old
episodes they were like in a giant
[ __ ]
ceiling with a big warehouse with hot
models models aren't good audience
l.a suck it la ain't great
no no but there's some parts of la that
are cool
sure sure it's cool i mean the shows i
did in l.a the supernova shows
were pretty fun killer killer shows
oh man i'm at the cellar the other night
and i get on stage i've been on the road
for two and a half weeks first step back
going stage the comedy seller and i
can't get on without people yelling out
we might be drunk come on how great is
that yeah
or he was just an alcoholic i was
walking down seventh avenue the other
day
and this guy goes wait wait wait wait i
thought he was mad at me and he takes
his phone out
and it's he's playing me too on the
phone crazy
i love it we appreciate it folks god
bless all your friends
and remember to email us for the patreon
and it might be drunk pod at gmail.com
and subscribe to that patreon hello dot
com
slash we might be drunk i want to make
sure you we're not [ __ ] you on time
mark
because i know you got it okay okay well
then give me a bit a bit all right
i most of my new [ __ ] is either hitting
or just garbage so here's an idea i had
that i can't get the head i want to make
sure no one has done this
so it's about you know the cleveland
indians are now the guardians
you know and people are pissed off
people are like you know
i see people online like this is
[ __ ] you know this is
like there are people who react to this
the same way they react
to like when they find out someone's
trans right right well they're just like
oh that's your [ __ ] that's your name
really i don't believe that
are you gonna change your uniform yeah
the name's good
that's a great angle and the clothes the
clothes changing clothes like that's
nothing
right i have people who are like well
i'm only going to address you as the
indians
yeah it's like calling him bruce still
yeah it is
that's good that's good but then we're
yeah it's like i don't know there's
something to it i think guardians is so
weird guardians is not a great name the
logo is pretty cool that g with the ball
is pretty cool i like the g
with the ball but uh i wonder why they
chose that is that significant to
cleveland a guardian i mean i think of
like the indians are significant to
cleveland it ain't for a good reason
i'd like to hear what the native
americans think are they fans
that'd be funny clearly not i think
they've been pushing it
oh really i thought it was honky's
pushing it
i don't know i do think this is a good
sign i mean look at the cleveland
indians though the red face logo that
ain't a good look is that wahoo
yeah yeah look at that logo and tell me
if there was any other race if there
were flaws that were flying
true i mean it's like it's like you got
a bit it's a cool looking guy
but yeah well what about the irish guy
the notre dame dude ain't ain't too hot
looking either by the way
that's a good point i'm with you irish
nobody cares about their feelings
look at that guy with the irish that
guy's a piece of [ __ ]
pull up chief wahoo though that guy's at
a bar
but no one cares about racism against
white dudes i guess so yeah
oh that's bad that's the logo that's
what i'm saying
yeah well the brown one is think if that
was a black i think if that was a black
dude or an asian dude
yeah that'd be like menstrually think of
it was a jew
yeah it could pass
but yeah i had a guy heckle me at the
show i just brought it up and he goes
he goes charlie sheen didn't wear no
guardians jersey and i'm like yeah i
don't think that's charlie sheen's first
regret
all right he's got hiv positive
that's great yeah i got to keep that in
somehow oh yeah
yeah i will say maybe this is a horrible
take
i think the fact that we're down to
sports mascots is a good sign
we we we don't have any bigger fish to
fry in a way
i agree that's kind of nice it's
interesting i was looking up uh
other teams back in the day it's funny
like indians is definitely it's just a
bad one it's like
jim jeffries has the best bit on this
where he's like you can't you can't name
i'm trying to do the australian accent
you can't name a team
after a genocide ah and he's like and if
you think i'm wrong think about how
you'd feel about a soccer team named the
munich jews
right right which i think is pretty fair
munich is what
what makes that so smart yeah that's
great
yeah he's pretty good that jeffries he's
a funny guy yeah what were you gonna say
sally i saw you oh yeah
this guy also his character from the
cleveland indians used to also go by the
name
chief nakahoma um as in nakahoma
naca oh naka homer yeah that's fun
yeah and believe me like i'm not for i'm
like i'm not a guy who's like
into political correctness at all but
that logo is not good that's a crazy
logo yeah
i will say uh oh [ __ ] i forgot my point
this uh
sweet and sour what's it called
whiskey sour is this it's a really good
drink very good
i got a fat buzz on i got to work
tonight too i'm i'm in the uh
brokerage so oh [ __ ] all right you got a
little time to tell you
to eat this away but uh
i can't remember damn i do i think
guardian sucks but yeah
what are you gonna i don't i think all
team names take a minute i
i do maybe like i think they're news
here like uh but
i've never like heard a new name where
i've been like that's like when the
when the sonics i think the sonics were
such a cool name
when the seattle sonic yeah moved became
the oklahoma thunder and i was like
that's
blame but then i'm like no the thunder's
kind of fun now yeah well what the
[ __ ] a denver nugget i know it's a
gold nugget but nugget just sounds rough
to me
but the logo the the old school jerseys
the blue ones pull up those like old
blue jerseys they're so [ __ ]
yeah called the vintage blue nuggets
jerseys
i gotta be honest this is controversial
i don't love the name the saints
i grew up with the saints i know it's a
fleur-de-lis it's the world
that is a cool logo those are badass wow
that's a great set that's one of my
favorite like the old nuggets jerseys
those are bad ass
that is cool i would wear that good
colors good colors
yeah i'm with you saints is not great
it's kind of religious well it's like
weird you have the saints
there's the angels there's the devils oh
like how many
like it's such a white devils is so much
cooler than [ __ ] angels
angels the angels are boring they don't
do anything fun you got a bunch of
alcoholics doing blow and hang
banging hookers called the angels it
doesn't work and there's no fear with an
angel los angeles
save angels but it's still boring still
boring city of angels
but new orleans saints saints come
marching in isn't that your song
it is but i don't know we want to have
this tigers and a saint
what else is here you gotta have the
priest the clergyman the bishops
i guess you got cardinals but that's the
bird cardinals isn't great either
cardinals is kind of cool that's kind of
classic it's classic all right
cardinals i'm okay that's like a classic
name better than the pigeon i guess
pigeons is kind of fun man the the
brooklyn pigeons
that's true they're if they're like a
wily kind of rough and tumble team
that'd be fun pigeons are just fun
animals they're just so [ __ ] grungy
in new york yeah
i do go to like atlantic city and see
seagulls i'm like well you think you're
[ __ ] better than us
they got that attitude they're on the
beach i'm in the [ __ ] pigeons are dirty
yeah they're dingy as the other rats
with wings they're f
i'm yeah but you know what i'll get near
a pigeon you're pro pigeon
i won't get near a wrap i'll get near a
pigeon interesting
pigeons are part of the [ __ ] city
baby that's true but what about the
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] they [ __ ] on the statues
they [ __ ] on the uh
on the buildings like your car gets [ __ ]
on i don't know yeah you know what
it's their city too that's what i say
they earned it when they put their time
in they
they they're they're fighting to survive
and i respect it the way that
they used to used to hide under the ac
and just hear them go
yeah under the heater that's true
like oh my god are they [ __ ] in there
yeah like get out of there they'd run
out like a family just right
yeah also one of the great scenes in
every cliche movie where the guy goes
no pigeons fly away
you gotta have that one give me a bit uh
well if we're going down the uh
the race thing and the pc stuff
fun idea maybe it's been done stop me if
it has
i feel like we're doing a good job of
like scrubbing racism now you know like
we're getting rid of statues we're
taking the n-word out of uh mark twain
all these things so i wonder if in like
a hundred years
no one will believe we were racist
because there's no evidence if we keep
taking stuff away
you're like no they were bad it's like
the book just says jim
i don't know what's the problem
yeah i think i think obviously there's
google and [ __ ] but it's kind of funny
to
like of an amish guy yeah will be there
will be like uh
you know radio hosts like there's no
evidence that we were ever
actually racist right that to me is the
funniest part oh that's interesting like
some rush limbaugh type
yeah yeah i could see that he's like oh
yeah we got the country from
indians we killed
he's like does that sound american to
you right right
yeah you i just think you got to have a
little bit of a criminal record you need
a record
so maybe either we get a wave although
the only way it doesn't work is if we
keep if we stay violent
oh yeah no one's gonna believe that we
weren't but the racism is interesting
like
it's too hard to cover it all up if we
get yeah we can't cover it all up
we're gonna have to get new statues yeah
this is a uh this is a i'm trying to
think like we get rid of a uh
like a robert e lee or something right
well he already did that
yeah we get rid of all the statues
maybe it's a it's a nothing bit because
it's almost too to
prove wrongable yeah it's funny it's
a silly idea it might be too disprovable
okay okay let me
give me another all right i want to do a
whole chunk almost like a carl ness
thing on things that we used to be
terrified of that just stopped
we stopped caring about yeah when i was
a kid
bermuda triangle was the biggest news
story the plane is gone
now did we fix that is that over acid
rain
what the hell happened to that ozone
layer was a huge
talk nobody talked about the ozone and
uh
the native americans used to cry all the
time on commercials
i think they stopped crying guess what
the casinos maybe they feel better but
it's just funny how
this is the biggest fear on the planet
and then it just 20 years go by and you
go oh whatever happened to that triangle
i think the fears keep getting worse aha
i think that's what happens we're like
now like now it's like ozone now it's
like really bad climate change [ __ ]
uh i think it's still the ozone is it
not is the ozone that's still a hole in
the ozone there's still a hole
yeah i feel like i heard about it every
two days the ozone watch out for the
ozone oh you're releasing that gas it's
gonna
[ __ ] up the ozone i'm trying to think of
the big it's funny that they talk about
like
if you make it smaller fears i think
like
bermuda triangle is a funny one yeah
that's something funny there
now it's like i think if it's like
they've been replaced and now they're so
much worse so like
realize that whatever time you're living
in
it's not as bad as it's going to be ah
yeah like this [ __ ] it's only getting
worse that's good
you know like okay like you're trying a
lot now you're like
uh i mean dude we're living we lived
through a [ __ ] pandemic and
there's still a variant like it's still
coming like it's still bad still keeps
going up
bp gulf of mexico that's it like oh you
have a black hole instead of a beam
right yeah it just keeps getting worse
but it'd be funny if
the bermuda triangle meets the global
warming at a bar and he's like oh man i
used to run this town he's like
you you got nothing old man you were now
yeah triangle's dead
i'm [ __ ] uh you know respect you
bermuda triangle yeah we got the
ice caps melting [ __ ] you i like the
idea of
uh it being like there's so much bad
[ __ ]
yeah and it's like i'm a little slow
right now
well you remember like the gas shortage
in the 70s and
uh you know the russians you know it was
everything there's always a fear
things are all things like yeah i mean
the cold war was a thing
right but i mean that's definitely
especially after
you know race for space and then like
nuclear weapons yeah and like nuclear
weapons were a thing
it's a and they are a thing right but
when when the fear is
lingering after something horrible
happened so after world war ii
or you know things like that and then
like it's tough because you're like well
this is just [ __ ] but then
like covers a few we never even
anticipated i know that to me is what's
funny is like the [ __ ] you worry about
hey guess what there's [ __ ] that's going
to hit you that you're not even aware of
good point good point yeah that's the
ultimate fear
yeah it's like the monster in the movie
you can't see
so you make it up it's like being
worried about jason and then a [ __ ]
piano just falls in your head
you know right it's like yeah we gotta
change the indians name and then you get
[ __ ] zika well that's what it all is
it's like
people are really at the core of it is
like is it a racist
logo absolutely but i think a lot of the
anger really does come
from just like needing a place to dump
the anchor
i agree because we all feel powerless
like
look at it this way like you could you
couldn't cancel donald trump
so you're canceling literally every
celebrity who has sexual misconduct
allegations you're like
okay well we can't trump has him and we
can't do anything to him
we can lead a mob against these people
right it's really about like i'm angry
and i need
something yes that's what people are
fighting for it's easy to change the
symbolic things and not anything deeper
yeah like the alcoholism and the uh
there's like you know mistreatment or
whatever of
native americans that should come first
before the
logo but i guess it's it's all a step in
the right direction but
i feel like the bigger problem the real
problems are so much harder to change so
if we can change this
we can feel good we feel better about
ourselves yeah
much easier oh yeah
yeah dude that was a dark ending yeah
yeah
sorry i think good man i pulled out well
these bits
i got you know racism taking away the
same here i i probably opened the door
with my [ __ ] half-baked horseshit
uh but we should we should plug gigs too
man i mean this pod is blowing up
is going great i'm i'm excited uh see me
on the road i'm in lexington kentucky
kansas city missouri portland oregon
royal oak michigan
boston boston massachusetts uh
atlanta georgia millersville
pennsylvania philadelphia
uh [ __ ] st louis missouri
all over the place samurail.com shows
hell yeah same here marknormancomedy.com
going to nashville going to buffalo
going to west palm beach
all over the place brea in uh california
say hello madison portland
you name it get on the patreon
we got to get some shirts we got new
patreon ideas too so uh
we got a bar now we got a danny boy we
got sally
this is about to really pop folks you're
right on the ground floor so
tell a friend spread the love spread the
cheeks
and queef it up thank you
no rick and morty talk this week
next week next week save that save that
in man great ending yeah say that
we'll say mark watch the pilot and i
have an ass and i'm saving it for the
episode
all right stick around got a lot of
thoughts we
might be drunk we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass
let's talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a
bit
maybe drunk we might be drunk